do you ponder your death your mortality
are you afraid of it i am a cryonics
customer that's what this little tag
around my deck says it says that if you
find me in a medical situation uh you
should call these people to enable the
cryonics transfer so
i am taking a long shot chance at living
a much longer life
can you explain
what cryonics is so
when medical science gives up on me
in this world instead of
burning me or letting worms eat me they
will freeze me
or at least freeze my head and
there's damage that happens in the
process of freezing the head but once
it's frozen it won't change for a very
long time chemically it'll just be
completely exactly the same
so future
technology might be able to revive me
and in fact i would be mainly counting
on the brain emulation scenario
which doesn't require reviving my entire
biological body it means i would be in a
computer simulation
and so
that's i think i've got at least a five
percent shot at that
and that's immortality
are you
most likely it won't happen and
therefore i'm sad that it won't happen
do you think immortality is something
that you would like to have
well i mean just like infinity i mean
you can't know until
forever which means never right so all
you can really you know the better
choices at each moment you want to keep
going
so i would like at every moment to have
the option to keep going
the the interesting thing about
human experience is that
the way you phrase it is exactly right
at every moment i would like to keep
going
but the thing that happens
uh
you know
leave them wanting more of whatever that
uh right that phrase is the thing that
happens is over time
uh it's possible for certain experiences
to become bland
and you become tired of them and that
actually
makes life um
really unpleasant
sorry it makes that experience really
unpleasant and perhaps you can
generalize that that to life itself if
you have a long enough horizon and so it
might happen but we might as well wait
and find out but then you're ending on
suffering
you know so
in the world of brain emulations i have
more options
oh you can return yourself that is i i
can make copies of myself archive copies
at various ages
and at a later age i could decide that
i'd rather replace myself with a new
copy from a younger age
so does a brain emulation
still operate in the physical space so
can we do what do you think about like
the metaverse and operating in virtual
reality so we can conjure up not just
emulate not just your own um
brain and body but the entirety of the
environment well most brain emulations
will in fact spose most of their time in
virtual reality but they wouldn't think
of it as virtual reality they would just
think of it as their usual reality
i mean the thing to notice i think in
our world most of us spend time most
time indoors and indoors we are
surrounded by
walls covered with paint and floors
covered with tile or rugs
most of our environment is artificial
it's constructed to be convenient for us
it's not the natural world that was
there before a virtual reality is
basically just like that
it is the environment that's comfortable
and convenient for you
and but if if when it's the right that
environment for you it's real for you
just like the room you're in right now
most likely is very real for you you're
not
focused on the fact that the paint is
hiding the actual studs behind the wall
and the actual wires and pipes and
everything else
the fact that we're hiding that from you
doesn't make it fake or unreal
you